[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ihr habt euch eine Fondantmotivtorte gewünscht
für Weihnachten
und hier kommt sie.
Heute gibt es eine schnelle, einfache,
aber trotzdem hoffentlich wunderschöne Fondanttorte.
Als Basis mache ich jetzt erst mal einen Rührteig.
Und den Kuchen, den habe ich euch
schon mal als Grundrezept auch gefilmt.
Allerdings, muss ich sagen,
ist das Video ein bisschen veraltet.
Also zeige ich euch heute erst noch einmal das Grundrezept.
Das ist ein lockerer Kuchenteig für Motivtorten.
Und die Zutaten könnt ihr im Prinzip auch selbst bestimmen.
Also die Grundlage, klar, sind Eier, Zucker,
eine Flüssigkeit, Öl und Mehl.
Und bei der Flüssigkeit könnt ihr einfach entscheiden,
welchen Geschmack euer Kuchen annehmen soll.
Ihr könnt da zum Beispiel Kaffee benutzen
oder Milch, Buttermilch, Eierlikör,
was auch immer ihr möchtet.
Ich benutze jetzt heute Eierlikör, den selbstgemachten.
Da könnt ihr selbst bestimmen,
ob er mit Alkohol oder ohne Alkohol sein soll.
Und so könnt ihr eben
den Geschmack des Kuchens definieren.
Ich mache jetzt das Ganze in 25 cm Größe
und brauche dafür
vier Eier,
200 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
jeweils 200 ml Eierlikör und Sonnenblumenöl,
400 Gramm Mehl
und ein Päckchen Backpulver,
das sind drei Teelöffel.
Ja. Die Zutaten sollten einfach alle zimmerwarm sein.
Die Eier gebe ich direkt in die Rührschüssel.
Ich lagere Eier auch immer bei Raumtemperatur.
Also ich kaufe die immer ganz frisch,
lagere sie bei Raumtemperatur.
Und es steht ja auch bei den Eiern drauf:
"Zu kühlen ab...".
Und bis dahin halten die es bei uns gar nicht aus.
Denn sie sind vorher schon aufgebraucht.
Daher habe ich die immer auf Raumtemperatur.
Dann kommt der Zucker dazu
und, wie gesagt, das Salz.
Und die Masse wird jetzt
für mindestens zehn bis fünfzehn Minuten verrührt,
bis es eine schöne dickflüssige Masse ist.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
meinen Backring vorbereiten.
Eigentlich braucht ihr jetzt kein Backpapier,
aber es kann sein,
dass der Teig bei euch vielleicht flüssiger ist,
falls ihr nicht mit einer Küchenmaschine arbeitet.
Und dann kann es passieren, dass er ausläuft am Rand.
Und den habe ich jetzt auf 25 cm eingestellt
und einfach noch mal 5 mm kleiner, also 24,5 cm.
Ich erkläre euch auch später warum.
Und den schlage ich jetzt kurz in Backpapier ein,
dass er wirklich komplett dicht ist.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommen hier die beiden Flüssigkeiten rein,
einmal das Öl und einmal der Eierlikör.
[Musik]
Kurz einrühren, aber wirklich ganz vorsichtig
und bei niedriger Stufe eher.
Und dann
das Backpulver mit dem Mehl vermischen,
gerne auch sieben.
So.
Mein Einhandsieb
wurde gerade gespült, ist nass.
Deswegen kann ich es nicht nehmen.
Da mache ich es jetzt so.
Und es ist auch gut, dass ich es gesiebt habe.
Guckt mal, das Backpulver.
Manchmal klumpt das nämlich
und dann verteilt es sich nicht im Teig.
Und dann ist es nicht gut.
Und jetzt einfach vorsichtig einrühren
oder auch gerne kurz noch mal mit der Maschine,
wie gesagt, niedrige Stufe.
Und hier jetzt aber nicht zu lange rühren,
sondern nur kurz, bis sich alles verbunden hat.
Denn ansonsten wird euer Kuchen matschig.
Und das wäre nicht so gut.
Und dann kommt der Teig direkt in die Form.
Den Ofen habe ich auch bereits vorgeheizt
auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Der sollte auch immer heiß sein, wenn der Teig fertig ist.
Also wirklich immer rechtzeitig daran denken.
Und ich mache es meistens mittlerweile auch so,
– meistens –
dass ich den
– also ich heize den Ofen gleich am Anfang vor.
Und in der App schreibe ich es auch mittlerweile so,
dass ihr ihn vorheizt und dann eben den Teig zubereitet,
weil ihr dann einfach nicht mehr daran denken müsst.
Vor allem, wenn man das einfach mal überliest,
dann hat man den Teig fertig, der Ofen ist kalt
und dann wird das Ganze nichts.
Ja, weil der braucht immer gleich die volle Hitze.
Und jetzt gerne am Rand so ein bisschen hochstreichen
und sofort backen.
[Musik]
So.
Dann eher im unteren Einschubfach schön backen.
Und während der hier backt,
kann ich mich schon mal um die Füllung kümmern.
[Musik]
Bei der Füllung, habe ich mir gedacht, nehmen wir jetzt auch
etwas leckeres Winterliches/Weihnachtliches.
Daher hier mal die Kaki-Frucht.
Ich glaube, auf meinem Kanal
habe ich noch nie was mit Kaki gemacht.
Aber ich liebe Kaki.
Also im Winter esse ich die wirklich total oft.
Und die hat auch jetzt im Winter Saison.
Von daher passt es auch ganz gut.
Da brauche ich gleich 800 Gramm vom Fruchtfleisch.
Also das sind jetzt bei mir etwa drei Stück,
habe ich mir abgewogen.
Und bei denen ist es so:
Wenn ihr die kauft, kann es sein,
dass die noch etwas fest sind.
Aber lasst sie dann einfach bei Raumtemperatur liegen,
damit sie ein bisschen nachreifen können.
Und je länger sie liegen, umso reifer sind sie.
Man sieht es hier auch schon.
Die ist schon ein bisschen überreif,
fast schon zu weich.
Die wird halt dann immer süßer und immer weicher.
Aber für meinen Zweck hier reicht das auf jeden Fall
und passt auch perfekt.
Dann nehme ich eine Orange.
Hier habe ich Gelierzucker,
– da nehme ich den 3:1-Zucker einfach zum Festigen –
zwei Sternanis
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und daraus koche ich jetzt eine Art Marmelade im Prinzip.
Also erst mal hier die Zutaten zur Seite.
Die Kaki habe ich bereits gewaschen.
Aber da werde ich jetzt die Schale entfernen,
weil die schon so ein bisschen
– ah, die kann schon ein bisschen holzig schmecken.
Deswegen nehmen wir die jetzt weg
einfach mit dem Sparschäler.
[Musik]
Dann schneide ich die Kaki einfach in Würfel.
Und ihr seht, die sieht im Innern richtig, richtig schön aus
wie so eine Art
– ja, wie so ein Stern irgendwie.
Ich mache auch damit noch ein Porridge.
Wobei, ich glaube, das Porridge-Rezept kommt vorher online.
Ich habe damit ein Porridge gemacht.
Ich finde die einfach so schön.
Und diese Sternform hier im Innern,
also das ist echt wie so eine Geleeschicht.
Du hast gesagt, du hast es noch nie probiert, nicht?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Willst du probieren?
>> JOSH: Also nicht bewusst auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich hole dir eine Gabel.
Denn die ist ein bisschen glitschig.
>> JOSH: Nicht, dass mir die Kamera aus der Hand rutscht.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Und hier innen ist halt echt so eine Glitschi-Schicht.
Und sie ist sehr süß.
Also die hat einen recht hohen Zuckergehalt.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und?
Voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und, guck, hier sieht man, da ist schon überreif ein bisschen.
Die ist so richtig glitschi.
Das ist für mich echt so mein Winterobst
und sollte man auf jeden Fall im Winter reichlich essen.
Denn zum einen ist sie gesund
und zum anderen gibt es die halt nur im Winter.
Also die gibt es dann auch nicht als getrocknete Version
oder im TK.
Die hat es einfach nur im Winter.
Mh, vielleicht trockne ich sie noch.
Ich dörre sie, glaube ich.
Und davon nehme ich jetzt, wie gesagt, 800 Gramm.
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Ja, Ela?
>> ELA: Wo ist Samira?
>> SALLY: Die Samira müsste drüben sein.
Was ist los?
>> ELA: Ich suche sie gerade.
Ich habe ganz viele Papierflieger gebastelt,
die wir werfen können.
>> SALLY: Ui!
Zeig sie mal dem Josh.
Hast du Papierflieger gemacht?
>> JOSH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Dann nehme ich hier noch Orangensaft dazu.
Ihr könnt auch ein bisschen Zitronensaft dazu geben,
wenn ihr wollt, wenn ihr noch etwas mehr Säure braucht.
Das kommt hier jetzt auch direkt mit rein.
Ich wiege das auch alles direkt auf der Waage ab.
Dann stimmen auf jeden Fall
auch die Mengenangaben für euch.
[Musik]
Zum Würzen gebe ich jetzt, wie gesagt, Sternanis dazu.
Dann noch etwas Vanilleextrakt, weil es gut passt.
Ich finde auch tatsächlich, dass die Kaki-Frucht
so ein bisschen nach Vanille sogar schmeckt.
Und jetzt Gelierzucker.
Der ist ja auch schon leicht säurehaltig.
Und dann einfach kurz einkochen
so für etwa fünf bis sechs Minuten
und ein bisschen ziehen lassen,
damit einfach der Sternanis
sein Aroma ein bisschen entfalten kann
und die Marmelade eben danach schmeckt.
Ihr könnt auch gern mit Zimt arbeiten
oder mit anderen Gewürzen.
Aber ich glaube, Sternanis passt hier ganz gut.
Wir lassen die Zuschauer entscheiden:
Heißt es SternAnis mit langem A
oder heißt es SternanIs mit langem I?
Das ist wie mit Oregano,
also OreganO und OrEgano.
>> JOSH: Oh, stimmt. Ja, ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Oh ja.
Und da ist...
Da streitet man sich gerne drum.
[Musik]
Und nach dem Kochen einfach abdecken,
den Herd ausschalten
und die Marmelade durchziehen lassen
und abkühlen lassen.
Der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt,
die Marmelade ist auch abgekühlt.
Und beim Kuchen habe ich es so gemacht:
Ich habe den direkt nach dem Backen
einfach auf ein Abkühlgitter gestellt, aber mit Tortenring,
und dann komplett erkalten lassen.
Jetzt kann ich hier
den Rand lösen.
[Musik]
Das Backpapier habe ich jetzt auch gelöst.
Und jetzt kann ich den Kuchen direkt schneiden,
am besten in
– ich glaube, drei Böden mache ich jetzt.
Das könnt ihr jetzt mit einer Tortensäge machen
oder auch mit einem Kuchenmesser.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich mir jetzt ein bisschen was
von der Kaki-Marmelade abgewogen
und mache jetzt eine Mascarponecreme daraus.
Ihr könnt jetzt für die Torte auch eine Buttercreme machen
oder die Torte mit Ganache füllen.
Aber ich möchte jetzt eher was Lockeres und Frisches.
Daher eben eine Quark-Mascarpone-Creme.
Ich brauche jetzt dafür hier noch etwas Sahne,
Quark, – das ist Quark in Magerstufe –
Mascarpone,
San-apart zum Festigen
und eben die Marmelade
und im Prinzip auch keinen Zucker mehr zusätzlich.
Denn die Marmelade ist ja süß genug.
Jetzt nehme ich die Marmelade.
Die kommt hier rein.
Achtet da einfach drauf,
dass der Sternanis weg ist.
Also den könnt ihr dann wirklich entfernen.
Und den Rest habe ich aber auch noch im Kühlschrank.
Dann die Mascarpone,
die das Ganze wunderbar cremig macht.
Ups!
>> JOSH: Ah, okay.
>> SALLY: Der Josh...
>> JOSH: Das hatten wir jetzt auch noch nicht.
>> SALLY: Der Josh lacht sich halt immer schlapp,
wenn bei mir was schiefläuft.
>> JOSH: Man müsste das, glaube ich,
mal ein bisschen mehr reinschneiden.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich glaube auch.
Die Ups-Szenen?
>> JOSH: Ja. Das...
>> SALLY: Ach, da
können wir so ein
>> JOSH: Das macht so ein...
>> SALLY: 3-Stunden-Video daraus machen.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt hier kurz verrühren.
[Musik]
Dann auch direkt den Quark dazu geben.
Und, wenn der Quark eingerührt ist,
noch die Sahne dazugießen und mit San-apart steif schlagen.
Nur aufpassen: Nicht überrühren.
[Musik]
Die Creme habe ich jetzt bereit.
Damit fülle ich, wie gesagt, die Torte.
Und, da es ja später eine Fondanttorte wird
und Fondant sich nicht so gut
mit Quark- und Sahnecremes verträgt,
muss ich so als Zwischenschicht
noch eine Ganache mit einbauen,
also außen und auch zum Glattstreichen der Torte.
Da habe ich jetzt bereits eine weiße Ganache vorbereitet.
Da gibt es ja auch ein Grundrezept auf meinem Kanal.
Ihr könnt auch eine dunkle Ganache nehmen
oder auch eine Buttercreme.
Aber wie gesagt,
Hauptsache, ihr habt außen was zum Isolieren.
Jetzt nehme ich hier einen Spritzbeutel
mit einer großen Lochtülle hier.
Dann einfach vorne die Spitze wegschneiden und umklappen
So.
Und da fülle ich jetzt die Ganache ein.
[Musik]
Dann geht es jetzt direkt ans Füllen der Torte.
Und dafür nehme ich jetzt
nicht den Tortenboden, also den untersten,
sondern hier den Deckel.
Der ist jetzt bei mir hier oben ein bisschen eingefallen,
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm.
Ich drehe den einfach um
und habe dann später außen eine schöne gerade Fläche.
Das kann ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen runterdrücken.
Und hier kommt jetzt, wie gesagt,
der Ganache-Ring einfach außenrum.
Bei mir ist die Ganache jetzt noch ein bisschen,
muss ich sagen, weich.
Ich stelle den Beutel auch ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Denn die Ganache wird ziemlich schnell fest.
Ojemine!
Ich seht schon, meine Ganache ist echt ein bisschen zu weich.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach ein bisschen Tortenrandfolie.
Ich hätte die tatsächlich ein bisschen kühl stellen müssen.
Aber
ich habe nicht daran gedacht.
Noch ein Ups-Moment.
Oh, noch ein Ups-Moment.
Jetzt häufen sie sich aber, Josh.
Jetzt übertreibe ich es aber.
Heieiei!
So.
So, so, so, so.
>> JOSH: Wo soll das nur enden?
>> SALLY: Wo soll das nur enden?
Es hat aber einen Vorteil:
Das hält jetzt schon fast von alleine,
ohne, dass ich es ankleben muss.
Wo habe ich denn den Kleber hin?
>> JOSH: Da vor dir.
Links unten vorne.
>> SALLY: Ah.
Ja, ich nehme jetzt einfach eine Tortenrandfolie.
Das passt.
Es war so gewollt.
Nein, war es nicht.
Aber, wie gesagt, wenn die Ganache fest genug ist,
dann klappt das ganz gut.
Ich muss sie jetzt leider hier am Rand so ein bisschen
hochdrücken, damit eben dieser Rand entstehen kann.
Ich hätte es euch gerne echt perfekt präsentiert.
Es tut mir leid.
Und hier kommt jetzt in die Mitte
die Tortencreme.
Ich war, glaube ich, auf eine höhere Torte eingestellt.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt megaviel Tortencreme gemacht.
Ich mache euch auf jeden Fall das angepasste Rezept
– stelle ich dann online,
also die Hälfte davon.
Und jetzt ist einfach nur wichtig, dass beim Füllen
wirklich die Sahnecreme nicht nach außen kommt.
Also, wenn es sein muss,
könnt ihr den Fondantring gerne noch ein bisschen erhöhen.
Und dann noch eine Schicht
Marmelade.
Guck, da ist der Sternanis.
Der sieht aus wie so eine Spinne da drin.
>> JOSH: Ja, irgendwie schon.
Dann kommt hier der mittlere Tortenboden rein.
Und dann das Gleiche noch einmal.
Außenrum der Fondantring
– der Ganache-Ring.
[Musik]
Gut.
Ich habe jetzt mal noch einen Tortenring drumherum,
dass es einfach stabiler ist, bis die Ganache fest ist.
Ist das okay für dich, Josh,
dass wir das heute so zeigen, so ein bisschen improvisiert?
>> JOSH: Ja. Ich glaube, das ist okay.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und jetzt als Abschluss
– schaut einmal her, wie schön! –
den Tortenboden.
So.
Jetzt ist das Dilemma gut versteckt.
Das habe ich gut hingekriegt.
Erst die Sauerei gemacht,
dann wieder
in Ordnung gebracht.
Jetzt werde ich die Torte abdecken.
Guckt mal. Das mache ich dann einfach
mit einem weiteren Tortenretter
und kann sie jetzt erst mal kühl stellen.
Die sollte jetzt auch wirklich komplett durchgekühlt sein.
Und deswegen stelle ich sie jetzt
bis morgen in den Kühlschrank,
räume hier in Ruhe auf
und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder,
wenn es darum geht, die Torte zu bestreichen
und zu dekorieren.
Tschau!
Willkommen zu Tag zwei!
Heute ist ein besserer Tag, habe ich im Gefühl.
Heute wird die Torte gut.
Hast du nicht im Gefühl?
>> JOSH: Doch, doch, doch. Voll, auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Dann ist es gut.
Hauptsache, wir sprechen eine Sprache.
Okay.
Also jetzt ist die Torte wunderbar durchgekühlt.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Folie auch wegnehmen.
Zack!
Und die kann man auch mehrfach verwenden.
Also jetzt einfach auswaschen,
wieder aufrollen und beim nächsten Mal wieder benutzen.
Und jetzt wird die Torte einmal komplett glatt gestrichen,
damit sie eben bereit ist für den Fondant.
Oh, hier waren noch ein paar Krümel.
Zack, zack!
Und dafür habe ich jetzt, wie gesagt, hier die Ganache.
Jetzt mache ich es zum einen erst mal so,
dass ich ein Ganaching Board nehme.
Und die sind nicht aus Plexiglas, sondern aus Polycarbonat.
Das ist nämlich ein viel, viel flexiblerer
und aber auch festerer Stoff.
Also den bekommt man echt auch nicht kaputt.
Wir waren neulich in
– war das auf der experimenta, Josh?
War das dort? Warst du da mit dabei?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: War das auf der experimenta?
Da waren wir, glaube ich, auf so Platten.
Und dann sind wir auf Holz gestiegen und so weiter.
Und Polycarbonat war der einzige Untergrund,
der nicht durchgebrochen ist, wenn man so
mit voller Wucht draufgetreten ist.
Also das kriegt man halt echt nicht kaputt.
Und damit werde ich jetzt die Torte glatt streichen.
Und deswegen habe ich auch gestern
den Backring ein paar Millimeter kleiner eingestellt.
Denn ihr seht auch hier, wenn ich es hier drauflege:
Das hier hat 25 cm im Durchmesser
und die Torte ist einfach ein My kleiner,
also so ein kleines, kleines bisschen.
Jetzt habe ich hier einmal die obere.
Dann löse ich hier unten
die Torte einmal ab,
damit da gleich nichts dran haftet.
So.
Kurz stürzen.
Dann hier die zweite Platte.
Und ich drehe es einfach wieder um,
weil ich möchte, dass beim Anschnitt
die Marmelade obendrauf liegt.
Und jetzt habe ich hier die perfekte Lücke
zwischen Torte und Ganaching Board,
um die Torte an den Rändern optimal glatt zu bekommen.
Das heißt, ich nehme jetzt hier die Ganache
und streiche jetzt erst mal so eine erste Schicht hier rein.
So werden auch diese feinen Krümel am Rand gebunden.
Und normalerweise mache ich es so,
dass ich eine dünne Schicht mache,
das Ganze kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Dann kommt es noch mal raus
und wird komplett glatt gestrichen.
Aber, wenn ihr mit so einem Ganaching Board arbeitet,
dann habt ihr es eigentlich im Prinzip
in wenigeren Arbeitsschritten.
Wirklich hier einfach schön die Lücken ausfüllen.
[Musik]
Und ihr könnt auch gerne kontrollieren,
ob die Platten optimal übereinander liegen,
dass sie eben nicht verschoben sind.
Denn sonst wird die Torte schief.
Ich nehme da immer auch ganz gerne so eine Teigkarte.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kühle ich die Torte kurz,
dass die erste Schicht so ein bisschen fest wird.
Und danach gehe ich noch einmal drüber
und dann ist sie perfekt.
Für die Deko nehme ich jetzt hier ein bisschen Blütenpaste.
Das ist nämlich eine Masse, die einfach schön aushärtet.
Ihr könnt aber auch Fondant nehmen
und mit CMC-Pulver verkneten.
Das ist einfach Cellulosepulver.
Und da nehmt ihr nämlich einfach
pro 250 Gramm Fondant etwa einen Teelöffel CMC.
Und dann härtet auch der Fondant nämlich aus.
Genau.
Denn ich möchte, dass die Deko jetzt schön fest wird.
Das könnt ihr auch gerne schon vorher vorbereiten.
Jetzt mit ein bisschen Bäckerstärke ausrollen.
Und man kann Blütenpaste übrigens
auch sehr, sehr dünn ausrollen.
Aber auch den Fondant,
– den zeige ich euch ja später –
den kann man auch superdünn ausrollen.
Aber, wie gesagt, der hier härtet einfach schön aus.
Ihr könnt ja mal generell sagen,
ob ihr noch mal so ein Basic sehen wollt zu Fondanttorten.
Denn ich muss sagen,
das andere Basic ist schon eine Weile her.
So Fondanttorten glatt streichen und überziehen,
ob ich da einfach noch mal ein Basic machen soll.
Und wenn ja, könnt ihr einfach eure Fragen
rund um Fondant, um Modelliermasse,
Modellierschokolade, Marzipan
einfach unter diesem Video sammeln.
Und dann kann ich noch mal ein Basic-Video dazu drehen.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier einfach verschiedene Ausstecher,
diese Eiskristalle
oder auch hier diesen Weihnachtsbaum,
Sternchen, Herzchen,
alles, was eben schön zur Torte passt.
[Musik]
Und ich lege die ausgestochenen Teile einfach hier
auf meine Schaummatte.
Da habe ich schon ein Stück Küchenrolle drauf.
Denn später werde ich die noch besprühen mit Farbe.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr die ausgestochenen Teile
vorher so ein bisschen strukturieren wollt,
könnt ihr einfach hier Küchenrolle nehmen
und je nachdem, was für eine Struktur ihr drauf habt,
drauflegen,
drüberrollen.
Ah, ich muss es gleich noch mal frisch machen.
Der hier ist jetzt schon zu angetrocknet.
Aber, wenn ich es gleich,
wenn es noch dicker ist, frisch mache,
dann habt ihr einfach die Struktur mit drin.
Das machen wir gleich noch mal.
[Musik]
Und hier bei diesen Ausstechern,
da streiche ich immer mit den Fingern so ein bisschen drüber,
damit die Ränder schön sauber sind.
Guckt mal. Dann sind sie perfekt.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Torte wieder fest.
Die übrige Ganache, wenn die euch mal zu fest wird,
könnt ihr sie einfach in der Mikrowelle
oder über dem warmen Wasserbad
nochmals erwärmen.
Und jetzt hier
einfach schön hier reinstreichen.
[Musik]
Und dann hat man wirklich nur noch diese kleinen Minilücken.
Und die könnt ihr dann so einzeln hier ausstopfen,
einmal noch mal abziehen
und dann ist der Rand wirklich schön perfekt.
Jetzt stelle ich die Torte
noch einmal ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann kann ich jetzt hier mit der restlichen Ganache
einfach noch die Oberfläche glätten.
Guckt mal. Da setzt ihr nämlich eine Palette an
und durch die Drehbewegung
streicht ihr die Ganache nach außen.
Und den Rand
streicht ihr dann mit so einer Winkelpalette rein.
[Musik]
Ja.
Ich würde mal sagen, Augenmaß
– im Augenmaß ist sie gerade.
Dann stelle ich die jetzt in den Kühlschrank
und kann in der Zwischenzeit den Fondant weich kneten.
Denn der Untergrund ist jetzt gemacht,
die Torte ist gefüllt und glatt gestrichen
und jetzt geht es endlich an die Deko.
Das ist eigentlich immer so der Moment,
auf den ich lange warte.
Denn das Füllen ist halt schon immer aufwendig,
vor allem,
weil ich nicht einfach so einen Schokoboden
mit einer Vanillecreme füllen will,
sondern auch immer versuche,
geschmacklich was Neues mit reinzubringen.
Daher dauert das eben seine Zeit.
Wie bei einem Haus: erst das Fundament,
dann das Innenleben hier
und dann am Ende die Fassade.
Und die kommt jetzt.
Okay, es war beim Hausbau anders,
aber ist egal.
Die Grundstruktur steht
und jetzt kommt die Dekoration.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier grünen Fondant.
Das ist eine Zuckerüberzugsmasse.
Und ich nehme noch ein bisschen Schwarz.
Denn ich möchte jetzt kein Grasgrün,
sondern eher ein Tannengrün,
also ein bisschen dunkler.
Und daher werde ich jetzt den Fondant schön weich kneten
und ein bisschen Schwarz einkneten.
Man muss da einfach ein bisschen mehr nehmen,
weil man den Fondant größer ausrollt als die Torte.
Es bleibt dann immer ein bisschen was übrig.
Aber den Rest könnt ihr einfach luftdicht verpacken.
[Musik]
Das sind so die Momente, an denen ich mich frage,
warum ich keine Handschuhe anhatte.
Es geht durch das Waschen wieder raus, aber
trotzdem ärgerlich.
[Musik]
Oh, ist das eine schöne Farbe!
Ich habe jetzt hier auf dem Ausrollstab
übrigens gerade die 3-mm-Abstandsringe.
Guckt mal. Dann ist der Fondant nämlich richtig gleichmäßig.
Und diese kleinen Luftbläschen, die kann ich noch aufstechen
und einmal drüberollen.
Dann sind die auch weg. Dann sieht man die nicht mehr.
[Musik]
Jetzt werde ich die Torte
ein bisschen mit Backtrennspray einsprühen,
damit die Oberfläche nicht so trocken ist
und der Fondant gut haftet.
Und das Ganaching Board, was noch drunter ist,
das nehme ich später einfach weg.
Und guckt mal.
Immer, wenn ihr Fondant auf Bäckerstärke ausrollt,
habt ihr den Vorteil,
dass man die Bäckerstärke einfach entfernen kann.
Deswegen nehme ich immer Bäckerstärke
statt Puderzucker oder normaler Speisestärke,
weil die sich einfach nicht rückstandslos entfernen lassen,
aber die Bäckerstärke schon.
Und jetzt könnt ihr zuerst die Oberfläche glätten
und die Luftblasen nach außen streichen
und dann den Fondant nach unten hin glatt drücken.
Und ich mache es immer so:
Die eine Hand hält den Fondant
und zieht ihn so ein bisschen nach außen,
um die Streifen und die Falten zu entfernen.
Und die andere Hand, die drückt ihn vorsichtig glatt.
Wie so ein Kleid sieht das immer aus!
Ein Hut.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier die Überreste
einfach mit einem Modelliermesser weg.
[Musik]
Und den kleinen Rest hier,
den kann ich jetzt luftdicht verpacken
und einfach beim nächsten Mal wieder benutzen.
Jetzt noch die Oberfläche und die Seiten glätten.
Das ist voll praktisch mit dem Ganaching Board drunter,
weil es so glatt ist und sich von alleine dreht,
wenn man es so ein bisschen anstupst.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr diese Kante hier außen
noch ein bisschen kantiger haben wollt,
könnt ihr auch mit so einer Fondantecke arbeiten,
die hier ansetzen und vorsichtig die Kante formen
und vorsichtig euch die Kante geben.
Hat sie nicht gesagt.
So.
So reicht mir das schon.
Wenn man noch ein paarmal mehr außenrum fährt,
dann wird sie wirklich kantig,
aber ich finde sie so echt schon perfekt.
[Musik]
Das Problem mit dem Umsetzen könnt ihr übrigens umgehen,
wenn ihr das Ganaching Board
gegen ein Cake Board tauscht, also diese Pappboard,
was ihr dann eben drunter habt.
Das bleibt dann aber auch drunter.
Und damit könnt ihr die Torte eben auch gut bewegen
und auf eine Tortenplatte setzen.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich wollte es jetzt hier
einfach komplett ohne machen.
Wie ihr seht, ist es ein bisschen schwierig, aber es geht.
Ich meine, der Abschluss hier ist sauberer,
wenn man es wirklich mit dem Cake Board drunter draufsetzt,
aber so ist der Anschnitt später schöner.
Dann habe ich nämlich nichts mehr da drunter.
Jetzt nehme ich hier meinen Prägestempel
und setze den hier außen an
und kann damit noch ein schönes Muster erzeugen am Rand.
[Musik]
Und da achtet ihr einfach drauf,
dass der Prägestempel unten an der Tortenplatte aufsitzt.
Und dann wirklich in einer Bewegung
so ein bisschen drücken, auch hier in der Mitte.
Der Kunststoff ist ja biegsam.
Der biegt sich dann so ein bisschen mit um die Torte.
Dann wegnehmen und dort wieder ansetzen,
wo eben dieses Muster aufhört.
Das ist ja so ein unendliches Muster,
das heißt, das kann man wirklich
einmal komplett rundherum machen.
[Musik]
Das ging jetzt einmal rundherum.
Und ich wollte noch sagen:
Wenn ihr viel Glück habt,
dann geht es nahtlos über.
Und ich hatte echt viel Glück.
Ich sehe nicht mal mehr den Übergang.
Dann kommt die Torte so
jetzt erst mal kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Und ich kümmere mich noch mal um die Deko.
Die wird jetzt nämlich noch gold.
Meine Deko ist jetzt schön angetrocknet.
Und einen Teil lasse ich weiß.
Den möchte ich dann so gern auf die Torte setzen.
Und den anderen Part, den werde ich jetzt
mit Gold und Kupfer so ein bisschen einsprühen.
Das sind auch alles essbare Farben.
Und die verleihen dem Ganzen
einfach einen schönen Schimmer.
Und dafür habe ich jetzt hier das Krepppapier drunter
– nicht Krepp, Küchenpapier.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Deko drauflegen.
Und ich habe mir gedacht:
einfach hier wie so eine Art Kranz.
Was ihr hier auch machen könnt
– also ich lege es jetzt erst mal hin
und dann klebe ich es fest, wenn es mir gefällt.
Was ihr hier auch machen könnt:
Ihr könnt auch noch so Ferrero Rocher nehmen
oder andere Süßigkeiten, die noch gold ansprühen
und mit drauflegen.
Dann habt ihr auch so ein bisschen,
ja, verschiedene Ebenen.
Ich hatte jetzt tatsächlich nur keine Süßigkeiten mehr da.
Sonst hätte ich sie mit benutzt.
Was ich aber auch noch nehme, sind Perlen,
also essbare.
Und dann
klebe ich das.
Ja, ich klebe es jetzt schon.
[Musik]
Guck. Ich habe hier Klebepunkte hin
und auf die Klebepunkte kannst du jetzt die Perlen kleben.
>> ELA: Mami?
>> SALLY: Guck, hier sind die Perlen.
Und überall da, wo Kleber ist, eine Perle drauf und andrücken.
Bist du etwa eine kleine Anna?
Hallo Anna!
>> ELA: Ich bin...
>> SALLY: Wo ist denn deine Schwester, die Elsa?
>> ELA: Rapunzel.
>> SALLY: Jetzt bin ich am Überlegen:
Da jetzt noch "Frohe Weihnachten" drauf oder nicht?
Ich glaube, ich lasse die Torte so.
[Musik]
Ich habe es jetzt nicht über mein Herz gebracht.
Ich musste jetzt doch kurz noch mal
den Josh Ferrero Rocher kaufen lassen
und habe die jetzt mit Gold eingestäubt.
Also eigentlich könnt ihr auch das Spray benutzen,
aber gerade bei so runden Dingen finde ich es einfacher,
wenn man Goldpulver benutzt.
Das ist das hier.
Und dann
– man muss auch nichts vorher drauf machen,
also kein Backtrennspray oder nichts.
Es haftet wirklich supergut dran.
Und ich habe jetzt kurz überlegt,
ob ich sie symmetrisch oder asymmetrisch mache,
aber ich glaube, ich bleibe bei dem Gedanken asymmetrisch.
Einfach so ein bisschen draufsetzen.
Und ich finde, dadurch bekommt sie
so ein bisschen die Höhe
und dann passt es.
[Musik]
Murat, was sagst du jetzt zu der Torte?
>> MURAT: Wunderschön.
>> SALLY: Eben hat er gemacht so: "Mh."
Also ich will jetzt mal nur den Josh kurz loben,
der das mit dem Rosmarin hier als Idee mit reingebracht hat.
Du bist eigentlich Konditormeister, oder?
Und Inneneinrichter.
>> JOSH: Okay, jetzt...
Ja. Jetzt kann ich es verraten.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Jetzt machen wir noch schöne Fotos und dann probieren wir
die Kaki-Torte.
Da ist nämlich Kaki im Innern.
Das habe ich schon wieder ganz vergessen.
>> JOSH: Stimmt, ich auch.
>> SALLY: Krass, nicht?
>> JOSH: Ich sehe nur noch
goldene Süßigkeiten und Rosmarin.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
Ich denke mir gerade so jetzt, wo ich die Farbe hier sehe,
die hätte auch geil gepasst
so dazu.
So als Farbtupfer.
Aber ich finde, so ist sie
edel,
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: zurückhaltend und dennoch beeindruckend.
[Musik]
Heute darf Samira probieren.
Wie findest du die Weihnachtstorte?
>> SAMIRA: Voll cool!
Auch mit dem Rosmarin.
Und die Farbe vom Fondant ist auch schön.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich muss das Messer kurz sauber machen.
>> SAMIRA: Ich finde ein ganz kleines bisschen Weiß.
>> SALLY: Echt? Aber ich wollte die so dunkel.
Die sieht aus wie drüben unser Sofa.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, das stimmt.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, das Sofa hat mich
so indirekt manipuliert,
beeinflusst.
Ich finde, der Rosmarin, der verbreitet einfach
einen leckeren Duft!
>> SAMIRA: Und jetzt habe ich hier überall Gold.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Das passt einfach perfekt alles.
Okay.
Samira,
dann...
Schön, he?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, dann probier mal.
Darf ich mit dir probieren?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Lecker!
Ich mag das vor allem voll,
wenn...
Also mir ist bei Fondanttorten, bei Motivtorten allgemein
– klar, die müssen gut aussehen.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Aber mir ist es wichtiger, dass sie gut schmecken.
Und da muss ich sagen:
Die schmeckt wirklich perfekt!
Was ich noch hätte reinmachen können tatsächlich,
wäre ein Crunch.
Mehr fehlt so ein bisschen der Crunch.
Aber ich höre es gerade bei Samira.
Die knabbert ja hier die Rocher-Praline.
Von daher hat man ja da den Crunch mit dabei.
Aber die Torte, die schmeckt richtig,
ja, so nicht sommerlich fruchtig,
sondern eher so, ja, so winterlich fruchtig,
also echt gut,
aber trotzdem frisch durch den Quark.
Hm?
>> SAMIRA: Ich wollte gerade sagen:
Ist da noch ein bisschen Frischkäse drinnen?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Quark und Mascarpone.
>> SAMIRA: Mmh!
Und Pfirsich, gell?
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Soll ich dir sagen was?
Mh.
Kaki.
Kennst du Kaki?
>> SAMIRA: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Mh, warte. Ich hole dir.
>> SAMIRA: Ich würde auch gern mal
eine Kiwifrucht probieren,
so eine Kiwibeere.
>> SALLY: Ja, Kiwibeeren sind auch süß.
Guck.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das ist Kaki.
>> SAMIRA: Die habe ich schon mal gesehen.
>> SALLY: Hm. Und die ist da drin.
Cool, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also hier ist unsere Weihnachtstorte.
Ihr könnt ja mal gerne mir unter das Kommen-
– unter das Video schreiben,
ob sie euch gefällt,
und vor allem, ob ihr sie nachmachen werdet dieses Jahr.
Ich habe aber natürlich auch weitere
ausgefallene Weihnachtstorten bereits auf meinem Kanal.
Schaut sie euch gerne an.
Und dann wünsche ich euch ganz viel Spaß dabei!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
Weißt du noch, die Rentiertorte, Rudolph?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die war auch cool, gell?
Denn ich habe viele Fondanttorten,
aber auch viele Weihnachtstorten ohne Fondant.
>> SAMIRA: Mh!
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> SAMIRA: Weißt du noch, die Rentier-Cupcakes
>> SALLY: Oh, die waren auch cool!
>> SAMIRA: in der alten Wohnung?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ja.
So.
Komm.
Nimm du das mit.
Und dann gehen wir.
[Musik]